What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience fast,
right?
I wonder that.
Yeah,
there's some people I think give him a quick dose,
you know,
like,
cause I,
I swell,
I respect Brian and his further to my point,
similar to the hunt in argument,
I can be,
you know,
I happen to believe in God,
but like I,
when I talked to Brian Cox,
I got to the point where I was saying,
all right,
even though I believe in God and you are a an atheist,
although he said I don't call myself an atheist.
Well I felt like we both got to the point where we said compassion,
kindness and love are the most important thing.
So in this way,
who cares?
So when you see there,
when you say you believe in God,
do you believe in the traditional God of Christianity?
What do you do?
You believe in God as a concept.
You have your own definition for it.
That I believe that that state of oneness and transcendence that you're talking
about when you threw your DMT experiences that says,
you know,
love and kindness and love and awareness,
I believe that is the most real thing.
I think that proceeded all matter.
And I think that we,
that we can interact with it.
So I don't believe that God in a sort of,
in just a guy away,
that the whole world is like an interactive by biological living,
breathing goddess.
I believe that we,
I believe yes,
that and that we can commune with it.
And I am.
Furthermore,
the relevance of it for me is that it,
it suggests to me that we should be acting kindly and lovingly.
And when we're thinking about how do we organize our systems,
but our awareness of that energy accessible to all of us should be paramount in
our understanding of how we organize.
So like what I think is like that we should look at,
you know,
like we've been through as human beings,
so many advents that agriculture technology industry thinking that we were the,
the,
you know,
the sun went round.
They're thinking that the earth was flat with all due respect to Eddie Bravo,
you know,
and we,
and,
and before each of these realizations in each of these changes,
we always think we are at the summit.
We never know what's gonna be.
The thing that's going to change.
My suspicion is that what's going to change is the way we relate to
consciousness and the way we see ourselves as individuals that we start to have
an understanding that what?
That that becomes a priority.
That thing you've described of like when I've come back from DMT trips,
I recognize this is just an illusion and it's not real.
I think that we'll start like I believe that we need to prioritize that and
progressing along that line.
What are the implications of this not being the most real frequency there is?
How do we organize society on that basis?
How does that affect how we relate to one another?
What kind of,
how should we be governing?
How?
How does that affect justice?
That that should be in the mix instead of what are many fucking terrifying
arachnoid weird gait robot motherfuckers.
Can we cook up,
you know,
like that's the way we're going,
the progressive technological route because it's created medicine because it
saves so many lives because it's given us wonderful technology,
the spirit of entrepreneurialship.
But all of that energy,
it all gets pushed in one direction.
It all goes that way.
And I feel that we need to invite that back.
The sacred and the divine need to be back in the conversation.
Well,
there's certainly going to be pros and cons with everything.
You know,
there's definitely pros and cons with the creation of technology.
I think of this,
I think of human beings as com.
If you go back to single celled organisms,
they have very little awareness of their environment.
And then as it became primitive bugs,
you know,
as,
as things evolved,
they develop more awareness.
But even us in comparison to certain animals,
certain narrow animals have heightened senses of smell and survival instincts.
But they're also colorblind,
you know,
and they,
they,
they don't see things.
They see edge detection like this.
One of the things about deer,
um,
they see movement.
So like if you wear camouflage and you know your,
your pattern is broken up with a grid and then you stay put,
they don't see you.
Yeah,
they just did.
It doesn't mean it doesn't register to them.
They see movement.
So we have a far more complex system of recognition than they do in terms of
like visually the way we see things.
And I think that whatever skills or whatever senses that we've evolved,
I don't think that's it.
I don't think that we've reached the pinnacle of it and I think that as beings
become more and more evolved,
they'll probably gain more and more senses and that could be directly related to
technology.
It's totally possible that what's going on with technologies that we're also
developing through external means a way for us to see the world,
a way for us to view like what they've done with the large Hadron collider is
like the best example of it,
right?
What they do with the Hubble space telescope and other telescopes.
You're using technology to gain awareness and to see more things and that this
is the good side of technologies,
that it's allowing us to have a far greater understanding of all the variables
that surround us that we might not be able to detect with our senses.
Yes,
this is a part of who we are and then I think when you're talking about things
like psychedelic experiences,
that's probably another realm of understanding that we haven't really achieved
yet because we're,
we're still evolving as,
as a,
as a species,
as a thing.